our gun brass did you miss me I'd forgot
to start recording there we go
I miss you too rose I hope you had a
great Easter I had a lot of fun but it's
good to back it's good to be back I'm
like is that all these new mats for me
today I'm pretty sure most of these math
arrow runs did I play this it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter we're doing
this anyway
hardcore ah hey I'm alive
let's go are you okay back there Don cat
don't bother on track sit still what the
[ __ ] are you doing telling a joke bye
bye bye bye bye there we go there we go
Irie sculpture your face hope you're
happy you're a you know what what did it
say ah shot of a [ __ ] I can still make
it
jackass dad died I probably Megan Fox's
hair god dammit
hey I can see my arm but I can see my I
can lick my elbow isn't that impossible
it's like come on circle house we're
gonna do this oh yeah dog cat ah [ __ ] my
truck what stop it with your Spanish
[ __ ] that's what you get did someone say
something because I totally did not hear
anything your animal oh you're not about
yes I'm a tie a headshot I'm a head your
[ __ ] on my head hey I got
penetrated by a hedgehog wha well
there's an that fun thing throw the ball
I you must know I'm pretty lead at these
I have been by leads I mean I play on
the night and I didn't get that single
point but it's okay it doesn't matter
but there we go mine is one god damn it
I'm time pass - all the time alright
throw you double throw who don't believe
you know huh what's that what's that
what's my
double-edged Andheri I want to see you
to a double legendary girl boy I want
well this is way too easy for me delight
into her triple o
it's not even difficult give me a
quadruple nipple legendary now whatever
doesn't doesn't matter doesn't matter as
long as you have fun that's all that
matters in my opinion stupid bog get off
me
throw you where's my wait wait a second
here
wait a second wait don't scroll up you
silly pants best back best back back off
boss I'm talking about my hair
alright best friend let me see this
dharak you had two got a million score I
got two we let's go why I'm not uh I
should be a medalist I'll forgive them
for now learn to fly let's go shut up
down free fun break shut up dog I'm
recording here
try looping whoa
don't die oh my god oh my god ah ah yeah
yeah made it like a boss rabbit chain of
the chain is a Hello jetpack are you
doing let me kiss you may I come in ah
damn it no one is good as best back I
wish no one where they ever be as good
as best back oh no oh no oh yeah well
gotta practice and wells done
oh no no Frank back spit yeah I'm good
pass through there that oh don't touch
anything not touch whoop oh [ __ ] I
taught you ah dah but it does what is
necessary it's fabulous
I'm keeping this with me we're doing
this together yes that's chimera jet
pack
now you just guessed you and me jetpack
things like for playing whatever I'll
give that one a rating because I always
forget to give them rating but that's
okay
epic arrow time that sounds like another
dad please wait hi how are you
that's what you get for singing it's a
pesto all right I've assets down well
what are you dying can't you just sit
back there is shut up her please are we
even going forward no we're not stupid
ass heart but daddy
ouch my nipples how's it even possible
well ah that's right Hank that why does
it always got my eyes on out of all
places
oh damn it okay fine hit my ass I'll see
if I can yeah I actually like tried but
[ __ ] all right bike what do you want to
do with me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate bike what are
you bike run away with his own era and I
don't see this one more time one more
time gone Shriram braid backflip get
shut out back that [ __ ] tagged otherö by
tag does a dodge dodge far away whoa
what where are you going oh nice I did
it for you I'm a hedgehog now ah okey I
don't care I run away with Mike stop
humping old man Jesus guys the challenge
too
I guess I play the first one I think so
let's try this one alright I am real
level JB
well don't god damn it I'm a Justin
Bieber and I take it in the butt just
like JB - all right come on that's bad
on it that's what I love took my heart
let's jot him a [ __ ] give me back my
heart that's why they will pay for that
all right there we go here we go whoa
that's Bob what's going on hey I'm a
giraffe awesome
I don't think of a Vespa we're together
now hey I'm still doing this okay
whatever
Sibiu I can finish this come on no no no
no no no no yeah yeah all right let's
grab it like it's hot ah ah [ __ ] Meg
whoa hey I didn't actually want you to
Best Buy only you can [ __ ] me oh yeah
all right
not even a bronze lat oh yay me oh
that's bad
yes but [ __ ] my arms oh it's okay
okay that's not Jeff Dan's difficult
lame I'm not lame Jamie's lay members
Lane right front back left double back
flip of engines all right Auto well
every 100 jumping all right son
dad word are we doing another map of
killing people
no we're going to the park I promise dad
you promised go [ __ ]
hey I'm a limbo to the limit come here
legs come here legs
thanks for doing dad hell is right with
all right here we go again go far son
Wow
damn it oh whoa Castello that I can sell
that don't care about
oh no I'm back
hey I became like him I don't know I
don't even net yeah all right yeah hey
happy now bye I know you love it I know
you can
what a first time I'm actually proud of
you I always I could be there to give me
a hug no to [ __ ] slap your I [ __ ] I
hate you because you're [ __ ] gay
I'm not homophobic it's just that you're
just so annoying and uh oh my god
I got like two into the cash oh yeah all
right I know that I got a rope
I haven't played a rope in a while so
this is the easy part
challenge accepted - whoa that's my arm
don't need arms open the vagina hole of
hell this is rough god damn it did I
make it easy part
double challenge accepted not a problem
front flip
who said that Oh grab it grab it grab it
yeah Oh
if Pig it was here yeah I would just die
oh what the hell oh hey how's this hard
this is softer than him
I almost said it really inappropriate
God I can kiss my toes it means always
wanted to do that all right let's go
let's go now back to short they always
fail at everything how angry right now
but first I must crawl forward and do
backflip forward dude the bots will work
every time even in the club I'm a girl
you seen his move and I do the butt rub
ah how's that even possible
am I still alive perhaps perhaps no come
on baby girl we can do it tonight I just
rub my body but John fall open the John
hole do the backflip yeah yeah
backflip Avengers front flip distressful
ooh lost my legs I grab my legs and I
throw it cuz I'm passed off down on
downs with my leg it's a flag and then I
forget to grab the rope another eight
and I haven't leg come back now like
I should give best song ah now my arm
it's okay I always want to have a still
alive but just still alive do the dance
doing the dance doing the bunga bunga
puta Pongo ain't no party like a poop a
party girl I'm putting my party yeah
yeah my life flapper I'm like a booty
pie party trap you're a charm like a
PewDiePie party eat you're on like a
please buy party no no no I'm like a
beautify yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah ain't no pilot sorry I could
do that all day
hmm you should do a livestream when I
only do that for 24 hours double cannon
bar though I lost my helmet there we go
you touch it like it how yeah grab all
right here we I was again drop of
difficulty Oh son of a B what are you
doing he's like possessors having blade
position all right god damn it's
difficult
don't look at me like that you're like
all I would do that in two seconds well
you probably would but it doesn't matter
cuz I'm doing it alright you just shut
up and watch what I'm just kidding you
can we can
alright that's okay I always want to be
split in half I get them and I'm dead
well legs what are you doing back is
there difficult come on
during this for Lady Gaga and Rihanna
mostly Lady Gaga's I love that girl I'm
alive it just touched my balls a little
bit not a problem
my leg is stuck goddammit yeah yeah oh
no I thought I could okay
tired face mode alright got a swinging
back and forth just like a penis
there we go got a problem no problem my
life whoa
bye there we go yeah take me miss ba
practicing Vespa position in the mean
time all right and then we let go here
yes yes I think we will end this episode
here because I am pretty proud of myself
well I can baby should be enjoyed
subscribe to come abroad today and I'll
see you in the next episode of video
that I make and that's pretty much it
[Music]
not good to see you